so und jetzt freue ich mich auf jens
spahn den der britische guardian schon
als kommenden bundeskanzler sieht er ist
einer der jungen hoffnungsträger der cdu
und wie wir neulich schon mal in dieser
sendung gezeigt haben er wird bei cdu
parteitagen mit wertvollen geschenken
verwöhnt
es gibt in unserem land noch viele harte
nüsse die wir politisch knacken müssen
und als kleines symbol und fleisch für
die echten kleinen nüsse diesen
handgemachten bisschen mehr dass ich
schon freuen können hier sich ein
schwarm an damen und herren
herr spahn schön dass sie da sind ich
unterstelle mal in dieser nussknacker
den wir gerade gesehen haben
der hat doch garantiert inzwischen einen
ehrenplatz in ihrer der liegt an der
seite in meinem büro der muss noch ein
paar nüsse knacken hat er noch nicht ja
kommt kommt da kommt also kommen so
super geschenk idee jedenfalls von der
jungen union
so ist machen wir zum warmwerden gleich
mal ein rollenspiel herr sparen
ich bin jetzt mal die spd super rolle
mal solche ja genau
damit kann ich mich identifizieren also
ich bin jetzt mal die spd und habe trotz
meiner leistung ist in der gruppe vier
jahre in der öffentlichkeit auf die
fresse gekriegt jetzt erklären sie mir
mal warum um himmels willen sollte ich
mich die nächsten vier jahre wieder von
euch zu klump regieren lassen erklären
sie mir das aber bitte in einfachen
worten ich bin die spd erst mal wäre es
wichtig ein bisschen selbstbewusster
heran zu gehen weil sie haben in den
letzten vier jahren sind sie nun mit mir
reden ich habe schlimmes durch das tor
also du hast ja viel erreicht besuchten
uns jetzt schon ich sollte ich soll doch
zensieren bin auch genoss ich dachte
sensibel sind hier
du hast ja viel erreicht in den letzten
vier jahren liebe spd du musst nur ein
bisschen mehr darüber reden und es
irgendwie gut finden was sie geschafft
das dann glaubens dir vielleicht auch
die wähler so wer teil eins ja der
zweite teil ist offenkundig gibt es hier
ein echt tolles land zu regieren also
ich glaub 90 prozent der politiker
deutschland jetzt deutschland ja ja ja
ich meine 90 prozent der politiker auf
der welt würden wahrscheinlich gerne so
ein land wie deutschland regieren und
all das andere sorgen
ja ich daher nicht dass alles rosig ist
aber ich glaube im vergleich zu vielen
anderen ländern geht es uns hier schon
ziemlich gut und ich verstehe gar nicht
warum es um getänzelt darum gibt dieses
land mitregieren zu können das ist
eigentlich eine ziemlich schöne chance
finde ich und wenn du da lieber spd sich
dazu entscheiden könnte es mit uns die
nächsten vier jahre zu gestalten dann
wäre das war schön ist ja super
angebaggert so jetzt aber jetzt mal
aber herr sparen das ändert ja nichts an
dem dilemma wir haben inzwischen
verstanden die bürger in deutschland
wünschen sich unterscheidbare
volksparteien was man auch verstehen
kann jetzt wenn wir auf die nächste
brutto zu steuern müsst ihr euch wieder
auf die zu bewegen die sich wieder auf
euch ist es auf dauer nicht doch so was
wie die ritueller selbstmord was da
passiert was nicht gut ist auf dauer ist
eine große koalition und vor allem in
unterscheidbarkeit verloren geht
menschen die zur wahl gehen wollen
auswahl haben die wollen wissen das ist
auch in unterschied macht ob ich cdu
werde oder spd wir haben schön ja ja das
ist auch ein auftrag für uns alle dass
wieder etwas deutlicher herauszuarbeiten
an notfalls mit nussknacker jedenfalls
hinfahrt haben wir beide union wie spd
zusammen 14 prozentpunkte verloren bei
der wahl und deswegen kann es halt nicht
einfach noch einmal vier jahre so
weitergehen kann ich finde die
entscheidende frage ist haben wir was
verstanden
von dem was da passiert ist ja mehr
vertrauen verloren das hat zu tun damit
dass menschen sich nicht mehr sicher
fühlen am hauptbahnhof das hat zu tun
mit der frage haben die das unter
kontrolle mit der migration und wir
haben auch ein bisschen wenig über
zukunft geredet über digitales über
bildung sondern viel über gegenwart und
die spannende frage ist kriegen wir
jetzt was anderes sind miteinander die
nächsten vier jahre
dann kann es gut werden und sonst jetzt
echt mühsam wir reden ja über groko 3.0
sowieso nur weil jamaika vor die wand
gefahren wurde
jetzt sind sie interessanterweise der
vermieter von christian linden haben sie
ihm wenigstens danach die heizung
heruntergedreht ist ja ich auch liberale
brauchen eine wohnung
also
und da kann ich privates und politisches
drin zahlt dann pünktlich weil ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass der linde am
ende so ein mietnomade ist er einfach
auszuspielen
die wohnung vermüllt zurücklässt ist nur
eine theorie waren sehen dann dabei als
die fdp da wie die sieben zwerge aus dem
raum gelagert ist was haben sie da
gedacht na ja ich war dabei jetzt hier
an dem sonntag nacht war es ja
mittlerweile schon gegangen sind dass
also es war ein bisschen komisch hat die
fdp verlässt geschlossen die den raum
sozusagen das gebäude und claudia roth
feld ich weiß garnicht markus söder war
nicht da alexander dobrindt und den hals
also dass ein csu ja das war also ganz
komisch weil csu und grün war ja vorher
sich nicht so grün fdp geht gerade also
es war schon eine komische szene an den
andern die ard jetzt im ernst die roth
hat vor lauter trauer mit dem csu typen
gekuschelt habe ich das
das habe ich noch nirgendwo gelesen muss
ich ehrlich sagen na ja es war so die
stimmung ich glaub so war sogar so aber
egal
irgendwer hat irgendwie komisch ist halt
ja nur was was da wirklich passiert ist
ja ist ja hat sich etwas verändert
insofern als über diese vier wochen
zusammen reden wir natürlich alle
miteinander ist ja ein bisschen
gruppentherapie gewesen
auch voneinander gelernt haben einfach
zu verstehen warum der andere was was
denkt hat ja tierisch was gebracht
na ja sie müssen sehen wir haben seit
zwölf jahren regiert und haben dann so
ein bisschen auch den anspruch jungs wir
wissen schon wie das geht
die anderen kommen aus zwölf jahren
opposition die grünen so aus der reinen
lehre zwölf jahre und jetzt will man
rein ins regieren die anderen kommen
irgendwo aus vier jahren
außerparlamentarischer opposition
eigentlich schon fast politisch tot
gewesen vor vier jahren
und das sind halt drei sehr
unterschiedliche situationen gewesen
und vielleicht war die zeit einfach
nicht reif dafür so als wenn nicht nur
inhalte es war so eine gesamtstimmung
glaube ich die am ende zu der
entscheidung geführt hat
ich bedaure das aber ich akzeptiere dass
auch am ende ich halte von diesem
nachtreten dass da einige machen gar
nichts
das sehe ich auch so ich hoffe trotzdem
dass ich diesen balkon nie wieder im
fernsehen sehen muss
eine eine sache noch irgendwer
modernisiert
weniger
die geschäftsführende regierung arbeitet
ja weiter als junger shooting-star der
cdu macht man sich in der berichtszeit
erst mal ich bin die tage als blutjungen
vorgestellt haben als cdu vize am ende
mit 37 noch blutjungen ist dann hat die
cdu ein problem das sage ich seit jahren
aber wird er sie könnten sie könnten ist
mir heute bei der vorbereitung auch wenn
sie könnten quasi mein sohn sein wenn
ich mit 13 abs
ich habe mehrere porträts über sie
natürlich gelesen ich schon über 50
fielen hier wie es geht
aber wenn die sekunde genau wenn dann
schnell schreiben
ich habe stern porträt über sie gelesen
und habe wieder was gelernt über
sogenannte parteifreunde denn ein nicht
namentlich nicht genannter parteifreund
von ihnen zitiert mit dem satz dem
sparen geht es immer nur um ihren sparen
verglichen mit sparen ist eine ich-ag
eine soziale veranstaltung der ist unser
markus söder also das letzte war
eindeutig eine beleidigung aber stimmt
der rest mal mir erstens mal wenn man
mitte dreißig kein ehrgeiz mehr hat dann
glaube ich mache etwas falsch dann wird
man irgendwie nicht anchorman wie es so
schön heißt einer eine heute show und
nicht erfolgreiche medien seien dann ist
man jetzt können sie wieder aufhört zu
schlagen
ich wundere mich manchmal dass das
irgendwie natürlich möchte ich gestalten
natürlich möchte ich vorankommen ich
glaube schon dass ich ein paar ideen
habe was was die digitalisierung angeht
was dieses älter werdende land angeht
mit denen ich eben auch was gestalten
möchte und nicht nur darüber reden
möchte und deswegen natürlich in
funktion kommen möchte erster teil
und zweitens geht es mir dann vor allem
auch um die sache ich diskutiere gern
auch kontrovers ich finde nichts
schlimmer langweiliger als eine
veranstaltung wo alle einer meinung sind
dann erst fängt die kiste oben richtig
an zu arbeiten wenn es auch mal rund
geht
und das heißt eben ich stelle mich gerne
auch mal hin und hab dann eine
diskussion mit viel emotionen dabei
solange man sich nicht an schreit
sondern um das bessere argument geht das
darum geht es mir so wenn einige daran
was anderes dazu sagen ja auch sich
damit umgehen aber wenn jemand schon
seinen namen nicht dazu sagt sagt das ja
alles sie beherrschte in jedem fall sehr
virtuos das spiel mit den medien ich
habe mir das mal angeguckt wie oft sie
es mit welcher geschichte auch medial
nach vorne geschafft haben sie sind
das erste mal aufgefallen als sie ich
glaube das muss so 28 oder 29 gewesen
sein
da haben sie öffentlich eine
rentenerhöhung kritisiert und da haben
sie sich direkt mit der kompletten
senioren-union verdorben
und ich glaube mit fast allen
zdf-zuschauern haben sie haben sie sehen
sind werden sie beraten in solchen
fragen haben sie ja von einer antenne
welche geschichten gerade ziehen
also das war tatsächlich 2008 wo es eine
außerplanmäßige rentenerhöhung gab es
gegen rentenerhöhung wenn die löhne
steigen steigen die renten alles prima
die letzten jahre
das war eine außerplanmäßige extra
erhöhung warum weil 2009
bundestagswahlen waren so simpel ist es
und was ich gesagt hat ist ich halte das
für falsch weil das müssen spätere
generationen bezahlen was wir da tun und
deswegen sollten wir es lassen
das waren natürlich die dieser verstehe
ich auch also wenn ich eine erhöhung
kriegen würde würde ich mich auch lieber
freuen wenn sie kommt als wenn sie nicht
kommt aber ich finde solche debatten
müssen halt miteinander aushalten vor
allem in diesem älter werdenden land
werden dann noch viel mehr solche
diskussionen kommen ich fürchte auch in
den 2030er jahren gehen jedes jahr
doppelt so viele menschen in rente
wie aus den schulen nachkommen zum
arbeiten und wenn sie dann in rente
gehen kommen halt relativ viel weniger
nach
also diese renten debatten werden auch
sehr emotional werden und wir sollten
uns mal lernen dass auszeit ich finde
übrigens völlig legitim dass man sagt
dass man was werden will
trotzdem haben inzwischen auch ein paar
parteifreunde ihn freunde in dem fall
wirkliche freunde gesagt pass auf du
gehst zu viel in talkshows ich bin ja
froh dass sie hier sind aber
zwischendurch hatte ich auch so ein
bisschen den eindruck dass sie jetzt
anfangen bei dem glasberg in die kulisse
reinzuwachsen
also wenn ich wenn ich rein gesetzt da
waren sich jemand da muss man aufpassen
dass man sich ein bisschen überdreht
dass man nicht irgendwann im goldenen
buch verliehen kriegt
mir ist eine gratwanderung
eine gratwanderung ich werde versucht
das auch natürlich so dosieren und zu
überlegen wann gehe ich in welche sind
hier und ich beibehalten nicht in jeder
sendung aber andersrum finde ich ist es
auch unser auftrag zu erklären was zu
tun und dafür hin zu stehen und auch mal
sind auch meistens die sendung wo es
dann mal etwas kontroverser wird etwa
bei der rente
wo viele dann auch eine position die man
nicht von jedem lieb gehabt wird auch
nicht einnehmen mögen und ich finde also
mir ist jedenfalls wichtig dass die
eingenommen wird und da wo es passt gehe
ich dann auch in der sendung aber sie
haben schon recht die eigentliche
politik wird nicht in sendungen gemacht
sondern im deutschen bundestag
ich weiß aus verschiedenen interviews
sie reden ungern über ihre kommende
kanzlerschaft trotzdem trotzdem nur eine
frage zum schluss stimmt das dass sie in
ihrer abi zeitung schon stand er wird
bundeskanzler
das stand da aber ob sie es glauben oder
nicht nicht von mir dahin geschrieben
guttenberg hatte das geschehen
man muss sich über jeden freuen wer was
werden will
und abgesehen davon es gibt doch in der
cdu auch noch andere die das theoretisch
machen können die an thronfolger job zum
beispiel die zeit haben wir es gar nicht
erspart vielen dank dass sie da waren
wir haben lange überlegt was wir ihnen
zum abschied schenken können dann ist
das ein gefahren ist ist ja ganz einfach
dass sie damals